did you know a Jeremy Renner had his own
app for a while no what's the app okay
first fans to get together and do it my
communicates my favorite story every
night an app for that maybe no this was
the thing apparently it was around for
like two years
Jeremy Renner put out an app which is
basically like Instagram except Jeremy
Renner sentry was he making money off it
while he was because you could buy stars
it was a free app but it was freemium so
once you download the app you can buy
stars and if you have a lot of stars
then Jeremy Renner is more likely to
reply to you I don't know I understand
he's in you know and game and all that
other he has that that many fans you
know about Jay wrens
is that with her call that's what
Jeremy's call James
Jay wrens he played Jeffrey Dahmer oh
yeah and if I'm the locker locker yeah I
was good in that yeah yes so Jay wrens
put out this app and like all the renter
heads get together and they just
celebrate jeremy renner and they post
their own profiles and everything he
taking himself a little Susan um a
little oh my god he created a said
goodbye he said goodbye because the app
does not have a verification system
right so what happened was some group of
trolls decided this is a great app we
have to take advantage of it partly
because there's no verification system
partly because the whole concept is
absurd like he's taking himself so
seriously we have to do something here
like they feel that they're doing the
Lord's work they are yeah so they
probably mad at everything you all will
get this whole story
good profiles started popping up of like
so Casey Anthony for instance posted a
profile remember Casey Anthony horse I
do what did she do may or may not have
killed her kid right right John Rutter
Fenn well apparently she's a Jeremy
Renner fan be serious while a profile
pops up and it's a picture of her and it
says it's Casey Anthony and she's got
her kid and everything and she's like
we're big fans and then somebody's like
this is disgusting get out of here
and then an account that says it is
jeremy renner said Casey Anthony is a
fan and all fans are welcome here if you
don't like it you can leave this there's
all these fake Jeremy Renner's on the
app there's all these people pretending
to be disgusting celebrities you know I
think there were men [ __ ] like look wow
Casey Anthony let her kid love Jeremy
Renner even though he's not designed for
children I'm gonna say it she's a pretty
crummy mom I tell you that guy really
hit the Delmon yeah pretty crummy Morty
crummy mom but I mean this was like like
the the app became complete and utter
chaos
it was inundated by people like I think
Jeffrey Epstein recently started he had
Phonak he did he did this was actually a
post-mortem oh yeah he was able to yeah
he was able to start his own account
they've got really good Wi-Fi hell yeah
perfect Wi-Fi yeah let me ask you was
this uh it was always only on your phone
it was just people just look at these
chats no it was an Instagram so Jarrett
J Rennes would post pictures and he
would communicate with you if you had
enough stars and then you could also
start your own account which is
ultimately the downfall because people
would start their own account since it's
some of the time they would portray less
than less than desirable people to be on
this app I mean there's a hero to
everyone criticizing my advocate Casey
Anthony has created an account and is
posting on the fan page spare me your
tears this is an all inclusive app if
you don't like it you are free to leave
and then someone writes you are not the
real Jeremy you are a big fake for rent
there's all these like jeremy renner
like obsessed fans who are being taken
advantage of so how many people were in
the app I don't know a lot it was 12
tens of 12 is around for two years yeah
that's around for two years yeah and
it's just called the Joe the J Renner
was called cheering up is called Jeremy
Renner and the app icon was a picture
Jeremy Renner's face and it'll go right
on your phone but it got inundated with
trolls a new jr. has he done enough for
on around like I get like music fans
getting
together and talking well he does use he
does he sings Oh was that talented so he
unfortunately what kind of music does he
sing good music is he the Elvis to
straight now okay yes yeah he's the
Elvis to heterosexual sexual yeah not
Elvis isn't the hell man if I knew if
you'd only known right you would've been
a red man yeah yeah
jeremy renner posted on the jeremy
renner hat by the way
it says goodbye dot dot dot like like he
even had anything to do weekly yes have
a verified account for himself on the j
random but yeah i'm jeremy like everyone
know was really him no verified apps no
verified accounts he says goodbye the
app has this app has jumped the shark
literally where ii think he meant
figuratively judah clever individuals
that were able to manipulate ways to
impersonate me when your to announce the
trolls got me yeah this is humiliating
about my favorite is he says what it was
supposed to be a place for fans to
connect with each other has turned into
a place that is everything i did test
and can't or won't condone or sit
connect with other fans of the same
actor of j read what do you want to talk
about rather i'm wondering cuz i'm
saying like you know so someone like you
know a huge singer something I
understand Elvis fans wanting to talk
about Elvis to a certain point yeah
right but imagine the frustration you
hear me Renner look I'm not saying it's
not talented I just can't fathom what
they're talking about well imagine the
frustration I've in your day-to-day life
encountering somebody like you Mateo who
I'm sitting here going
how great is jeremy renner and you're
like a guess
and I'm like no and I start talking
about Jeremy Renner and you go I don't
understand why we're talking about this
that's very frustrating to me as a
redhead so I cut my Jefferson I I go to
my jeremy renner app and finally there's
some like-minded okay alright connect
with I get it this is good too I love
the end of it he goes to all the
superfans which is like the most
self-important
to call your fans superfans to all the
superfans
who have supported me with your words or
encouragement amazing art stories and
time shared on the app a genuine thank
you and I hope to see you on Instagram
Twitter YouTube and Facebook sign Junior
this thing about jeremy renner je our
Instagram Twitter YouTube and Facebook
and Junior is written in a different
font yes a signature a larger way did
refund people who bought stars in the
last 90 days so he was not to screw
people over he just couldn't do it this
yeah but he got all the other stars okay
what do we guess I'm gonna guess one
point okay two point five million
jeremy renner I'm gonna get a six
hundred thousand fourteen point he's way
bigger okay then I take back what I said
I didn't realize he was that time I
didn't either I take back what I said
I guess you're handsome right here and
right now yeah but there are those
people like there are those celebrities
online who have those massive like more
followers than Mariah Carey they just
have massive rabid internet fan bases
and you'd never know I know it's weird
the rock is understandable but a hundred
and fifty five million right I
understand the rock good for Jeremy I
had no idea but he can't even exist it
that is how no matter how many fans you
have how many like corners of the
internet there are yeah that are just so
many rocks unturned I wouldn't even have
thought I was so off in the grass the
Internet is so big and there could be
there could be a fourteen point four
million number fan base million and you
have no idea to now how is his music so
good let's hear it a little bit I've
never I didn't know he did music he
thinks Triana Joe's public was that a
picture of Casey Anthony yeah oh you
want to see some more okay you can
scroll down this is the one we read if
there's a if there's some more yeah I'd
love to see what I'm Jeffrey Epstein
replied to Casey Anthony she did
see that yeah let's see that pull that
right back up so you're just having this
these conversations were seeing right
here actually takes me back to the old
AOL chat room yeah best when people
would just be like I'm Britney Spears
and you're like no you're not yet is and
they Jeremy right holy F is this real
after epstein response you get an AOL
turn your work Casey you get AOL Terms
of Service violations for impersonating
people so we're gonna hear his music
well let's let me read the Jeffrey
Epstein comment over on the last one
this one's on Casey Anthony's photo
Casey says candid photo time hey jeremy
renner I am your biggest fan so was my
kid my god hope you see this and then
emojis Jeffrey Epstein right guys I am
not dead nor am I in prison I am now
resting in my private island whilst
getting a [ __ ] by your boy Jeremiah
Brenner and Jeremy Renner wrote holy F
is this real and then somebody called
cranking for Junior right love your work
Casey you can see where somebody started
with good intentions for this app would
not love where it went and was that
other one you showed okay that is a
photo of Jeremy Renner and he's just got
a really sexy stare I'm German he says I
am Jeremy Renner caption says I'm Jeremy
Renner
are there any los angeles-area
I am Jeremy Renner Jeremy Renner had to
shut down his app because there were
people boys I'm looking for crack
cocaine D couldn't he just boot them i
under I know or put a star next so you
would think the real fans of Jeremy
Renner would know that it's not Jeremy
Renner this guy's been kicked off why
was this guy kicked off - Jeremy Renner
am what it is tweet say he had a fake
richard kind account who who makes a
richard kind account he's an actor
you'll know exactly who he is if story
yeah he's like one of the all-time
character actors yeah anything yeah you
know let's see what Richard contribution
right so jeremy renner the real jeremy
renner
writes happy Wednesday that's something
that us redheads call Wednesday
Wednesday you know Richard kind right
Jeremy it's me Richard Jerry it's me
Jerry it's me Richard I want to talk to
you about getting into music only fun
even ended in it's me Richard wrapping
up I want to hear some of this guy's
Tunes his tunes
Mary this is called that music video of
course you guys four million views yet
the redheads are serious this is called
main attraction by Jeremy Renner
oh my feels like an episode of Ghost
Adventures yeah Jeremy Renner is my
favorite in music right now I can see
that I love Jeremy Renner I missed the
app he
nice is he wearing a sweater from the
Liza Minnelli collection it's long it is
long hey why is he acting like he's
singing this live in the video
nice
[Music]
nice I don't hate it the video I don't
like it all I think I agree with you the
videos embarrassed it's ruining it for
me yeah but if I can't cuz he's thinking
he's really cool but it also kind of
sounds like everything else you know
what I mean like he got great producers
and it's like can you make me sound like
everything sounds like again I'm for him
for making his coin like he's getting
he's doing it he's crushing it but and
there's nothing more embarrassing than a
grown man singing strides in music so I
open with that there is a sense of
something not belonging something is
wrong he's an actor yeah good [ __ ] is a
good [ __ ] go to one more song something
please yeah maybe this is just a bad
video the video I don't realize you're
gonna be trashing Jeremy Renner today
we're not we're actually not Gemini
being is how did we describe this Jim
we're being we're being fairly fair
minded fair mine but yours cover of
house the Rising Sun oh good good I was
just thinking that this song needed a
really loves a trenchcoat yeah he does
when I saw it yeah he was a big Dylan
Eric fan
he loves the matrix the thing about
Jeremy Renner is he's brooding and
that's something that yeah I like about
him
[Music]
it sounds a little auto-tuned little bit
that's good
cartoons cool I can't understand a word
he's saying
yeah it's like the diction of a fog
machine look Bob Dylan wasn't that easy
to understand either
he also wrote his own music and you
don't think Jeremy Renner and Bob Dylan
are equals in music
saying that equals good how about heaven
don't have a name that's a good name for
so and they don't have a name yeah he
just called it by its name yep
makes sense no you're right had actually
Matteo there's a great video for this
like heaven doesn't have a name yet just
said the name then how did you call it
heaven Susan doesn't have a name and all
the music by the way doesn't feel the
same like it doesn't you listen to like
Beyonce there's a yeah you know it's a
Beyonce song rasa yeah oh this is a
younger video I think they're just
taking clips of his movement okay all
right
[Music]
yes voice sounds better here it's
crushing it Jade was a weird vibrato no
yeah
you know what you give you the most
famous actor in a world everybody wants
to be a rock star the videos are just
not great the music itself isn't this
isn't a video though this isn't it yeah
everybody wants to be a rock star yeah
like imagine dragons it sounds a lot
like imagine dragons or double dragon
yeah I love double dragon mm-hmm
the game the movie yeah whatever yeah
all of it yeah I'm surprised as to uh is
that oh I forgot it was an arrival I
don't like that move where people put
blankets on people after some kind of
accident I think that the last thing I
want when I'm like in a fire a blanket
yeah it's 80 degrees it's a way for me
something to do in a movie oh yeah yeah
it's a move it's a we understand that
this means this you know what is the one
with the giant egg alien ship that was
pretty that was it arrival is actually
good yeah interesting with a time worked
in a different way yeah all about
language and how we yeah yeah I like
that movie yeah arrival was pretty good
the nuclear weapon went off in there it
didn't matter
yeah I mean I don't feel any reason to
see it again yeah no you're right it
isn't like contact which I love I mean
how do you know my posture Conte yeah so
that's fantastic it was great but that
era of Jodie Foster is phenomenal it is
I love Jodie Fogg it was also written by
an astronomer Oh was it ii wrote that
book yeah Oh custard Foster's very
tight-lipped if she talks like I'm in
space right now I can see it's moving
she really had a run Jodie Foster she
had a great run yeah with like seven to
forty two yeah never greater she went
and the alien came to her in the form of
Hannibal Lecter can you imagine and
she's like oh [ __ ] here's what's good
about movies is when they cross over
yeah yeah yeah always good you're right
always a good move one more Jim and Sam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM app